now to the war in Ukraine and a dramatic
policy shift by the U.S in its support
for the Ukrainian military the country's
president that's Vladimir zielinski met
with President Biden and other world
leaders at the G7 Summit in Japan to
discuss the new military aid Deborah
patta has more on that part of the story
president zielinski has lobbied long and
hard for advanced fighter jets now after
a sudden about turn in U.S policy
Washington has agreed to let Western
allies Supply Kiev with American-made
F-16 Jets and will support a joint
effort to train Ukrainian fighter pilots
on them
ever the master of powerful symbols
zielinski used his visit to Hiroshima
which was obliterated by a World War II
atomic bomb to draw comparisons to the
devastated city of Bahamut
there is absolutely nothing left alive
all the buildings are destroyed he said
it is simply absolute total Destruction
zelinski was quick to deny Kremlin
claims that Bachman had been taken by
its forces but peering through the dense
fog of War makes it hard to determine if
the fighting in one of the longest and
bloodiest battles in this conflict
really has come to an end
Russian mercenaries from the Wagner
group staked their claim to the city and
the leader of the paramilitary group ye
Afghani pregozian posted this video
bragging that his private Army had taken
control of every inch
and while the Ukrainian Armed Forces
admitted losing ground they said they
still controlled areas Southwest of the
city and were advancing around its
flanks Ukraine's rallying cry has but so
long been bakmut holds but this past
week
has been burning
that battle has lasted over nine months
during which Bahamut has become a symbol
of fierce Ukrainian resistance but the
focus on the city could quickly shift
once that much talked about
counter-offensive yet underway Nate
Deborah Patton Ukraine thank you